point does a woman have permission to  leave a relationship because it's toxic  you know i i come from a two-parent  household so i don't know if i can speak  too self on the subject but  if the relationship at home is breaking  down it's not working  what what then um would allow the woman  to leave because children growing up in  a toxic household can't be much better  than people growing up with a single  parent that's co-parenting well mm-hmm  you know so like  but the numbers the numbers don't  support what you're saying  so the numbers it's really clear  single-parent households are worse off  than two-parent households  and to me personally i would say  cheating if it's like to the crazy right  um i think  abuse for sure um but  honestly like most things can be worked  out and if you're in a toxic  relationship like you have to look  internally because it takes two to tango  and you attract what you are